bon sans respect elle s'était donc le
premier face à face entre les deux
hommes depuis la crise déclenchée par
cette alliance en hand au pacifique
partenariat signé avec canberra et
londres dans le dos de paris qui s'est
vu on s'en souvient annulé un méga
contrat de vente de navires à
destination de l'australie opération
donc réconciliation ce vendredi entre
paris et washington
exactement sophie ce que nous avons fait
était maladroit et n'a pas été fait avec
beaucoup d'élégance c'est par ces mots
que joe biden a esquissé un mea culpa
assurant que la france était un
partenaire d'une extrême valeur un
échange qui semble donc acté le début de
normalisation des relations entre paris
et washington c'est désormais l'avenir
qu'il faut regarder a estimé de son côté
emmanuel macron le chef de l'état qui a
salué des décisions concrètes prises ou
annoncées après le début de la crise des
sous marins des décisions qui amorce
d'un processus de confiance entre les
deux pays je propose d'écouter emmanuel
macron et joe biden
je crois que c'était après nos deux
échanges mois de septembre au mois
d'octobre dernier
n encontre importance parce que je suis
à
l'affût rochus nous avons enclenché
véritablement un travail commun est une
réponse politique et une coordination
renforcée entre les états unis
et pour moi c'est l'avenir qu'il nous
faut regarder
ce que nous avons fait était maladroit
et n'a pas été fait avec beaucoup
d'élégance je veux être clair la france
est un partenaire d'une extrême valeur
[Musique]
il y a trop de choses que nous avons
accompli ensemble nous avons souffert et
célébrer ensemble rien ne peut
réellement gâcher cela
ces dernières semaines les deux pays ont
mené des consultations sur divers sujets
et parmi les attentes de la france il y
a le soutien est claire des états unis
au projet de défense européenne objectif
donc pour le chef de l'état montré que
ce projet qui lui tient à coeur est tout
à fait compatible avec l'otan sur la
forme les deux hommes se sont entretenus
en tête à tête avant d'être rejoints par
leurs délégations respectives il ya eu
des poignées de mains et parfois même
des sourires entre les deux hommes est
particularité de cette entrevue aussi
c'est qu'elle se déroule en terre
française à l'ambassade de france au
vatican symboliquement elle s'est donc
emmanuel macron qui a reçu joe biden et
dans les images des 84 voitures du
convoi américain qui se déplace donc à
l'ambassade de france on peut y voir un
signe de la volonté des états unis et
vient de recoller les morceaux avec la
france se place donc être désormais à
l'avenir ce qui compte c'est que c'est
ce que nous ferons dans les prochains
mois les prochaines semaines les
prochaines années a déclaré emmanuel
macron en anglais
merci beaucoup estelle fages en direct
de rome en italie